I think it was just like after
I had done the first project
and I saw the results of
I wasn't showing anyone.
It was just for myself.
Like it was like a high.
And I was like,
I want to keep figuring this out as I go.
In 2017,
a 23 year
old designer in Boston had an idea.
Nicole McLaughlin had taken an entry level
design job at Reebok.
But exposure to the waste inherent
in the manufacturing of apparel
inspired her to embark on a series of art
projects in her off hours.
She crafted Clever,
one of one footwear out of found objects
like tennis balls and badminton
paraphernalia.
Her work soon gained a cult following,
and as her audience exploded on
social media, she started her own company,
centered on art and upcycling,
teaching workshops and partnering
with blue chip brands
on a variety of environmentally
conscious design forward
projects, including collaborations
with Reebok and Vans.
And it all started with one idea.
How did your parents
professional life
inform your career ambitions?
My parents
are both pretty creative people,
so I feel like I was always around it
my whole life.
My dad was a carpenter
and then he ended up
becoming a mall manager,
so he was sort of around fashion.
And then my mom has always been an
interior designer for commercial spaces.
So from like my earliest memories,
there was always
carpet samples and like chairs in the back
seat of the car.
And there was always something
creative happening in my house.
Like they were very crafty and also
really good at working with what they had.
So I feel like that definitely
has influenced a lot of the decisions
that I make as a designer.
When would you say that you sort of fell
in love with graphic design?
I got a MacBook when I was in high school
and I got a cracked version of Illustrator
in Photoshop, and that's really
when I started doing editing
and doing some stuff on Illustrator.
But I think once I got to college,
that's really when I started
to learn more about graphic design
and that I realized also
that it could be done for clothing too.
Who were the designers or
what were the sort of brands or products
that were most influential on you
in that high school period?
My fashion sense was pretty interesting.
I was more into like skateboarding
and snowboarding,
so I wore a lot of vans
and I loved Burton.
And then also during high school,
I was really into sign language.
So I had a deaf relationship
when I was in high school
and I spent a lot of time on YouTube
like watching videos of people signing.
And so YouTube was really helpful.
I wasn't the best student.
So I think I learned a lot from other
people or watching other people do stuff.
And that definitely still applies today.
I get creative blocks a lot
and I find that
the best way to get through
it is to just continue to create.
I find that sometimes it's helpful
if I paint something or I take photos,
you know, taking a step back
and doing something else that's creative.
What do you feel like was
like the most important things
that you learned in college?
It allowed me some time to grow and
to meet people and try different things.
And I landed in digital media
and it was a pretty broad
major
that allowed you to just kind of explore
all different forms of doing photography,
doing videography, sound recording.
And I really appreciated that time.
And there was also a lot of equipment
that I could use for that for free.
But essentially to me, for free,
I was like, Oh,
I can use all this equipment.
And I really took advantage of that.
And that's how I learned
all the programs
and things I needed for my time at Reebok.
Did you have any sort of sense of what you
wanted to do as a career at that point?
I always was like tinkering
and using my hands to make stuff,
but I never would have thought that
what I do now is even a possibility.
Like, I knew the fashion industry existed
and I liked fashion,
but I didn't really understand that
as like a career choice, especially with
footwear and graphics
being applied to garments or to footwear.
So I found this internship working
for Reebok, and I just applied to it.
I had no idea,
like I thought I'd be doing graphics for
social media or graphics
that were meant for advertisements.
And then once I got there, I learned that
I was doing graphics for clothing,
and that was like the craziest experience
to learn how the fashion
industry works and understand
how close are made.
Once I learned all those things,
I was like,
This is definitely more of the direction
that I want to go in.
When you
applied for the internship at Reebok,
was this a paid internship?
It was paid, which was great, and I got
I moved to Boston, so
that was a really big change from college
to then moving to a new city.
It was all really exciting,
but really nerve racking, and I knew
it was kind of my chance to prove myself
and like get into the industry.
So I didn't waste a second of it.
And I worked really hard that whole year.
And what kind of stuff did
they have you making?
I was doing graphics for running.
That was what I was place
on, so I was doing repeat patterns
for tights, for shoes
and then I got put on this project,
which at the time I didn't even realize
like how much this would impact me.
But Reebok started doing collaborations
with some fashion brands,
and that mall at the time
was just kind of taking off.
And they did a club with Reebok
on an in-store pump theory,
so I had to take this shoe
that Donna essentially scribbled all over,
had to take it apart and recreate it
all in Photoshop to be able
to make it factory ready, and so that
they could make it in mass production.
And it took me weeks and weeks and weeks,
and I was like sleeping
at the office and stuff and yeah,
that's kind of where it all started.
I like the idea of work and I think
a lot of the people in this industry
say that luck is somehow
a factor in their success, whether it's
being at the right place at the right time
or discovering something at that moment.
But there's also just the layer
of being perceptive to things
and pushing yourself
to do the best you can do.
How does one transition from
this sort of one year internship program
to becoming a full time employee there?
It was kind of crazy because
they put us all against each other.
It was like all your friends
that you sat next to for a whole year.
They're like, Get to know each other.
And then they're like,
there's like one job.
So you all have to fight for it now.
And I think my competitive spirit
really came out and I was like,
I'm going to get this job
because I'm not moving back home
with my parents in New Jersey.
So I used that experience
and I built my portfolio
and I was thankful I got the job.
And so I was hired full time
doing graphics for Reebok Classics,
which was where I wanted to be
because it was all the really cool,
exciting products
that had the collaborations,
but also referenced all the archive stuff.
And Reebok has an amazing history.
It was really cool
to have that experience.
I got to do some cool stuff.
I got to do like throwback
Allen Iverson jerseys
and make all the cool graphics and stuff
for inline
apparel.
At what point in this journey
did you start working
on your own personal art projects?
So I had been working at Reebok
a couple years before
I started doing my personal projects.
I started to realize how much waste
there was coming out of the industry.
I would be sitting at my desk
and there'd be boxes of samples
just surrounding me,
and it's a half a pair.
That's the wrong color
or the wrong material.
So it kind of is just destined
to be trashed and thrown out.
And so I started to rummage and pick
through these things that they were
just going to get rid of
and taking them home with me, like
not really knowing what I was going to do,
but I was like,
I could really try to find a way
to use this.
I first started gluing everything,
and then from there
I was like all of a handsaw.
And then I got better every project.
When I say where my ideas
come from, it sounds a little bit corny,
but they really do come from everywhere.
I think a lot of the time material is used
only for its intended purpose,
so I like to try to change that.
You're a young person in a new city.
I imagine
you are pursuing an active social life
and you have other things going on
and you're also working your ass off at
your job.
Where's the motivation coming from
to be like, Oh, I'm going to spend like
12 hours at home tinkering with this thing
or teaching myself to sew without
a concrete end in mind.
I look back at that time and
I, I think it was just like after
I had done
the first project and I saw the results of
I wasn't showing anyone.
It was just for myself.
It made me feel really good and inspired
and I was like, I want to keep.
Like, it was like a high.
And I was like,
I want to keep figuring this out.
Like, what if I get better?
And like,
what if I just keep taking new materials
and figuring this out
as I go on the weekends?
I would go out
and try to rummage through thrift stores
and my house and everywhere.
Reebok had an office in Canton that
they closed, and I would go back there and
try to find materials
and take it home with me.
That energy was
just so high at the time to
How long
did it take from sort of starting to like,
acquire these skills to getting to a place
where you're even showing friends?
I'd say you're probably
I was making this stuff
just in my bedroom, not showing anybody.
And then I would show like some friends
and then I would be working
on stuff at my desk occasionally because
I was like, starting to take over my life.
It was like
the only thing I was thinking of.
And then I started posting on Social
and one of my first ones
that I felt good about that I posted it.
Someone was like,
Oh, was this an actual shoe?
And I was like,
Oh, that's like such a crazy complex.
I went from hot gluing something
to making something
that looked like
it could actually have been made.
And so from then I was just like,
Oh, I can just keep showing this
and show the progress of me making stuff.
And then a couple of months after that,
I made a series where I did a shoe out
of a tennis ball, shoe out of a volleyball
and a shoe out of a soccer ball.
And that's when I started to like, pick up
traction on like social and followers.
And it was really scary.
Honestly, I was not prepared for it
and I didn't realize how fast
that could happen.
It was exciting.
But also I was like, Do I have what
it takes to continue doing this?
And like, am I doing it for me
or am I doing it for them now?
This was always a creative side project
and I never wanted to lose that.
It was a really fast switch.
Like once
all the traction started, I was like,
Oh wow, I have to be taking this series.
After
getting her first taste of public success.
Nicole
continued to expand on her tradecraft,
including honing her skills
at the legendary Adidas Creator's Farm
as her unique passion
projects continued to attract attention.
She recognized an opportunity
to step out on her own
and found a company that could encompass
the breadth of her upcycling ambition,
from collabs to consulting to education.
During your time at Reebok,
you ended up going to work at the farm
in Adidas, the parent company of Reebok
work with Marc Dolce,
who was, you know, sort of a design guide.
What was that experience like
and how was it different
than the experience within Reebok?
The farm was this Disneyland
for designers.
Basically,
it was an office where people could come
and they had an unlimited resource
of materials
and a makerspace and knowledgeable
people who worked in there.
The designers from Adidas would come
and they would do a three month rotation.
And I was the first Reebok designer
that got offered the opportunity
to do the rotation at the farm.
So I was really, really excited for that.
And at the time I had just really started
doing my personal projects.
I was in such a creative space,
filled with so many creative people
that were almost on this
like sabbatical thing.
So yeah.
Are you working on like projects
that are meant to come to fruition
or is it more sort of like a R&D
like experimental thing?
A bit of both, but definitely more with
the intention of like creating projects
that would come out in
maybe three or four years time.
It was pretty advanced like timeline.
And so yeah, that was just like
a knowledge explosion during that time
and selling that, that was like
where I really got my skill set.
My biggest advantage as a
creator is to build, to show
what goes on in my mind physically.
I think it's a visual representation
of my thoughts
as you start to have these viral moments.
Is this something that is talked
about at Reebok
with your manager, with your team? And
the majority of the people I worked with
had no idea that this was happening.
And then there was one time
and this was the moment that I knew
it was time to quit.
I was in a meeting
and this outside marketing
agency
came in to do a presentation to Reebok,
and they put me in a deck and were like,
Oh, you should collaborate with this girl.
And I was sitting in the meeting
and all my coworkers, like, turned
and looked at me and I was like, Okay,
I guess
I got to do something about that.
I never thought that I would do freelance.
I never thought I would own a business.
I didn't understand anything about it.
I was kind of scared actually,
to even consider that, because in my head
I was like, I've made it Like I have a
like a corporate job that has like a name.
And, you know, I've worked
really hard to get here, but I knew that
I wasn't I'm not always going to have,
you know, the most popular social media.
I'm not always going to be
the most relevant.
And I'm totally fine with that.
But the moments that you do have it, it's
kind of like a make or break thing where
it's like, if you want to use this moment,
use it and capitalize on it.
And so I was like, Let's do it.
Making things the way that you do.
And they're all, you know,
sort of one of one's
or at least that, that in that moment
it was all one of ones.
The obvious path towards monetizing
that would be to go and sell them
and figure out whether, you know, it's on
some sort of marketplace or whatever.
You were very pointed
in, not wanting to sell these pieces.
What was the sort of motivation
philosophically to not have any sort
of commercial element
with the personal projects?
First of all, it's really challenging
to make these pieces sometimes
and like at scale,
if I was to sit there and make even only
ten or 20 versions of IS,
first of all, it's never going
to look exactly the same every time
something about it,
it's going to feel different.
And a lot of the time the material I use
there is only one I could find of it.
And sometimes I'm using mismatched
soles or,
you know, different parts of things
and it's hard to duplicate what I do.
Something that I always realized
as as a consumer myself.
Like you see stuff online and like
immediate, you're like, Oh, I like that.
I want to buy it.
And I don't feel like
everything needs to be purchased.
And so a lot of the pieces that I have
that are a bit like crazier, wild or
like you wouldn't have the same experience
even if you did own it.
Like, I think it's something
about what you get when you see it.
You have it, you feel it, and then
you kind of keep moving on it your day.
You'll come back and look at it
or reference it or however, but
you don't need to own it
to have an experience with it.
How you know, as you are thinking,
I'm going to quit my job
and pursue running my own,
you know, myself as a business kind of.
How were you thinking about monetizing it
and making it work financially?
It started actually with the workshops,
so that was my first opportunity
as a freelancer was like, Oh, well,
why don't you teach people how to sew?
Like if that's what you know,
how to do it?
And again, like I had just started this,
like I was not an expert, but I was like,
I can teach people if I could figure this
out, like people can do this.
I had that as an opportunity.
And then my first like bigger
brand project was
with a extension of Foot Locker.
It was called Green House,
and they offered me
a project
to do a collaboration with Crocs.
And so I was like, okay,
like I didn't know what that really meant.
And I was like, Can this be scaled
in a way that still feels like me,
that still has a part of my identity
in the ethos of upcycling, knowing that
it's still it's going to be created new?
How can I make this me?
And so that's sort of where it started.
And I saw a business opportunity
and then I started to realize
I can work with these companies
from the inside out.
So my experience from Reebok
really can apply here where it's like
these brands have all this stuff
and I know it because I've seen it.
How can we find a way to use it?
Can we bring this back into production?
Can we do workshops?
You know, there's to me
use dollar signs because it's material
that they're ready to throw away.
And I was like,
If I can make something cool out of it,
like, I'll take it and I'll, I'll use it.
And then they're like, Well,
how can we get involved in it?
My ultimate creative goal is
to make upcycling a more popular thing,
to be able to show the potential of waste
and to show that the fashion industry
as a whole can do a lot better.
What was the process
for putting together kind of the itinerary
or the curriculum for the workshops?
The workshops have always been more
How can someone leave
with a skill that they didn't have
when they came?
And I always thought
that sewing was really scary.
And I like
sometimes I still think it kind of scary.
And if you been in front of a sewing
machine before, it's like there's
a lot of power that you hold in your hands
and you're like,
I don't really know what I'm doing.
I want them to leave
with the finished product.
But if anything, if they can leave
with some type of skill set,
even if it is hands.
So just to be able to understand
how something is made,
I think is important
that can leave with them being able
to repair something or be able to hem
a pair of pants that they've drifted.
If we work with a brand, it's
a sponsored moment where they'll provide
a box of shoe samples or deadstock fabric
or clothes that are donated back to them.
And we'll use that.
And it's cool because they get to have
the discovery element of taking something
and flipping it inside out,
finding pockets, finding pollers,
and using everything that you
can because it's valuable.
You left
Reebok in 2019 and started this business
sort of in earnest,
going right into the pandemic.
How did that affect
kind of getting things off the ground?
That was really scary.
I think that was the craziest time
to decide to go freelance.
I was really nervous to make that jump.
And then once that happened
to, I was like, What am I going to do?
And also because my well of materials
just kind of dried up
because I didn't have Reebok materials
and all the thrift stores and things
that I was going to to get materials
I didn't have during COVID either.
So it really forced me to dig super deep.
And I was just using literally
everything in my house.
And I was getting really creative
with the stuff that I had.
And this is also around
the time that I started
taking apart
all the projects that I was making.
So I was like, I'll make it.
I'll take a picture of it,
I'll take it apart,
and then I can use that material again
for another project.
So a lot of the stuff that I've made, like
if finally seen it and you're like, Oh,
that's actually about the same.
So like, that's the same fleece material
that's been used, you know, at this point
dozens of times.
So I think is a really good thing
to happen.
And also started to realize
I needed to create boundaries
between me and my work too.
I think as a freelancer, you start
to realize, like you run a business
that becomes your whole entire life
and you never able to turn it off.
I was experiencing a lot of burnout
then I was like,
If I don't set these healthy boundaries
now, will I ever?
That was also a time of reflection
for me to really do
that.
Striking out on her own
just as the pandemic began,
would force Nicole to expand her DIY
toolkit even further.
Her technical skills and philosophy
regarding the creative process
would provide a broad foundation
for success, culminating with a satisfying
full circle moment.
I think it's interesting just hearing
the language used that you frame it
as going freelance as opposed to like
launching a brand or starting a company.
Do you still feel like
you are like a freelance designer,
or do you feel like you are,
you know, the captain of this enterprise?
I've legitimized the operation,
so I should have
I should graduate
from the term freelancer.
But for some reason in my head,
I mentally kind of still there.
I don't feel big enough,
I guess, to be a brand, but at this point,
like I am creating stuff
that people are wearing and buying.
So in a way,
like that's sort of how it is.
And I am an LLC and I pay people
and so it is a bigger ship,
then I'm still thinking it's a sailboat,
I guess, and it's actually like a ship,
but I like mentally kind of keeping
it still as like my personal project.
I don't want to lose that.
I'm like scared
that I'm going to lose that
because that's why I love it
so much and it's mine and I care about it
and I don't want it to become so big
that it's like a machine.
How would you describe your brand?
I have a couple different arms of it where
my personal work is still the forefront.
That's where I get my ideas.
I still love dedicating my time
to making things
and trying things out and knowing that
it's probably not going to work.
And then I have these brand projects
where it's a collaboration
and it's footwear, it's apparel.
They come to me, they have an idea
for a model of a shoe, and I'm like, Okay,
well what material do you have
that's potentially destined for the trash?
Like, can we use that?
Can we do a super small run?
And we can do a really like,
small customizable version of it
and make it a little bit crazier.
I think it's more about still, upcycling
is at the forefront of everything
and making responsible design choices
when it comes to sourcing materials.
But whimsy and fun is also
a big part of my friend, and my identity
is playfulness
and putting pockets on things that don't
maybe necessarily need a pocket,
but I think it does.
What are the qualities about yourself
that you hold on to the most tightly?
My childhood sense of wonder.
I think that's always been
a huge part of my work and just my life.
I love to have fun
and I don't always love to take things too
seriously, especially being in an industry
that is pretty serious at times.
I think it's always fun to approach it
with a lightheartedness,
and that's what's kind of kept me going.
A lot of the work you do is with brands,
which means that you have to
sort of interface with people there
and they have their own agenda
and their expectations that always
at the outset of these relationships
are aligned, at least on paper.
But then as it plays out, sometimes
there is it reveals a misalignment.
Yeah, I I've definitely experience that.
I'd say the majority of the time
the brands that I work
with kind of know
what they're signing up for.
And I'm not I'm not a safe designer
in any aspect of the process.
I like to sort of push my limits
and also the company
that I'm working with limits
on what they've made in the past
and what we can create together
that feels authentic to both of us.
But I think having the design, integrity
and also identity
for me is really important to keep secure.
Brands will come to me now for advice,
which I love, and they're like,
We don't know what to do
with all this stuff.
We have a box
that's sitting in the warehouse.
It's costing us more money
to have it in the warehouse
than it would be to get rid of it.
Let's call Nicole.
Like, what kind of things would that be?
It's crazy.
Like things that don't even make it
onto the floor at a store
because the tag on the clothes, like,
maybe created a small hole in it,
even if, like, there was a couple pieces
like that, they'll get sent back.
So like, it's
not even noticeable to a consumer or
if a roll of fabric has like one
water mark or some type of like
ink mark on one part of the roll,
the whole thing will get scrapped.
Just like we're testing.
They could be halfway
through like producing a shoe
and then something fails on it
and they're like, actually, nope,
we got to take everything
off the factory line and figure this out.
That's a big part
of what I've been doing now.
I love that type of work
and a lot of the time
the brand partnerships start
as like a social media ask
and then have turned
into this whole like I'm like,
let me take a look at your factory
and your business
and let's see what we can do here.
And definitely overstepping boundaries
as much as I possibly can.
How do you think about the content
that you're making?
And, you know,
the upside of social media
is the interconnectedness
and the fact that we can reach
so many people.
The downside is that, yes,
you know, that you're in a feedback loop,
even if you're trying to fight
being in that feedback loop.
I think at some point
I had to tune it out.
It's nice to be able to create
a place for conversation,
and I like that and I always I leave
comments are always on
because I want people to have a dialog.
But at the same time,
you shouldn't let what people say
always influence the decisions
that you're making.
And and over time I was like,
you know what?
People are going to have their opinions,
whether they like it or not.
They're thinking about it,
they're commenting on it.
And I think the ultimate message
that I'm trying to achieve
is getting people's
perception around waste.
And, you know, the
the bad side of the fashion industry.
I want people to change their minds
about this stuff.
And so as long as they're interacting
with it some way, it's helpful.
I think.
I think to be able to tell a good idea
from a bad idea, you have to do both.
And I definitely have experienced
a lot of bad ideas
and they somehow
always lead me in the right direction.
So I just kind of have to let it happen.
Has there
ever been a project that you've made
and felt
so good about and confident in
and then posted it and had it not connect?
A while ago
I had all this material from Puma
and it was samples
that were made for the Olympics
and it was like tracks, spikes and balls
and gloves and all these like things
that were meant to be for sport.
And I it was a sculptural piece
and it wasn't really meant to be wearable,
but it was meant to be more for display.
My idea was to make like art,
like a series of armor
out of all these, like track spikes
on, like, the arms and like,
I think that was definitely like
one of those times where I was like, okay,
like conceptual
doesn't always hit with the audience,
but to me
it really pushed my design skills.
And also
I got a lot of projects out of it.
I had so many people reference like brands
that came to me after that reference
that that image, and they were like,
This was like a sculpture.
Like we want something like this.
And I ended up doing a sculpture
for the Super Bowl
last year for Nike
because of that project.
And it was just kind of crazy
that that happened.
So I always have like people
that aren't really sure about
if they should post something or
if they think it's too out there, like not
their normal style, like go for it anyway,
because like, who cares about metrics?
At the end of the day,
if it's going to get you work
and it's going to get you the right
people's attention, you never know.
So it worked out.
Obviously,
as the business has grown
and the opportunities have grown,
you don't physically make every
single thing with your hands anymore.
You now have people that you work with.
How has it been to sort of detach yourself
from the physicality
of that part of the creation?
It's challenging.
I never thought that
I would give that part of it up,
but at some point I had to
to be able to be a business person
and be able to go and take meetings
and go places and and keep things running.
Because it used to be
if I had to travel somewhere,
everything stopped and I had to.
I was sewing in hotel rooms and like it,
it wasn't working for me.
So I found people that I really trust
and that understand me and my vision.
But also they have their own vision
as well and how we can work together.
And I think I still have a hand
in and everything.
And whether that's the concept
is usually coming, that's me usually.
And the physical making part of
it could be passed off to other people,
but it's, it's ours.
Like it still feels like a part of me
because it came from my brain.
And, you know, just because I didn't sit
there and physically so the whole thing.
But that was a big letting go moment.
And I think a lot of people experience
that as a creative.
But in any business sense
where it's like you were the one doing
every job and at some point it's like
you can't physically do everything.
So you're going
to have to be able to delegate.
And I've gotten better at it,
but it's always something
that I'm working on.
The most important idea that I've ever had
is letting go.
I think for me, my projects
are meant to live in a moment of time
and I never stay stuck on one thing.
You have
established yourself very prominently
in the footwear industry
without necessarily coming into it
as a sneakerhead
or really like sneaker enthusiast.
What would you say
is your sort of relationship to
sneakers at this point?
I do love sneakers,
and I didn't grow a sneaker head per se.
I mean, I always thought
about my footwear choices,
but it was always more
from a utility standpoint and it's
still a lot of
the time is what has brought me closer to
them is the history of shoes
and how inspiring that is to me.
Reebok's first running shoe
ever was like the first running shoe
and was it literally like nails
as track spikes?
If you even think about
like the first women's athletic shoe
was came out in the eighties,
like designed specifically for women
and like that's not that long ago.
You know it's like it's pretty crazy
to realize that we're in this moment.
So I think that's what really gets me
excited about footwear.
I love being able to contribute to that
in some way.
And yeah,
just seeing brands that are coming up
with really innovative things
and yeah, I just, I love that part of it.
You are wearing a collaboration
that you've recently released
with Reebok with your name on it.
This was a huge full circle moment for me
from being a literal intern
at the brand to having a shoe.
I just never would have thought
in my wildest dreams
the scared intern
that was afraid of everything.
And to now they came to me
with the model
and it was a women's specific model.
It's called the Go Mid
and I really loved it.
I just thought it was customizable.
There was a good canvas
for me to work off of
and it reminded me of this shoe
from the nineties called the Aetna.
And it's funny because that's really where
I pulled a lot of the inspiration from,
and I got to utilize
my knowledge of the Reebok archive
to be able to design my shoe
and also utilize
my knowledge of the company
as a whole, like the development team
and the marketing team
who I had worked with in the past.
So it was like, we don't need to
be introduced because I know you already.
And so it just worked really well.
Having that experience and being able
to kind of put myself to the test.
But yeah,
my parents could not believe
that I had my name on a shoe.
That was a really cool moment.
They were like, You,
your name is on there. Like that's.
Do they have pairs?
They do.
My mom is very she's sporting it.
Yeah.
What else is on the bucket list.
I definitely want to get more
into the homewares and furniture.
That was something that I've, I've dabbled
in the past couple of years and ultimate
dream of mine would be to have a kids
like a children's museum
and have it
be more of like a museum of science
or like an experimental type of place
where people can come and touch and create
and make things so like
almost like my workshops,
but in a larger sense
and kid friendly.
And also I have some
really crazy projects coming up
that I'm excited about.
And it is really it wasn't like dipping
a toe within the footwear industry.
I'm like fully submerging myself in it.
So I'm really excited to see how it goes
and also
how every project we can do can be closer
to being a fully upcycled shoe.
That's really the goal.
That's honestly like within a five year
plan is to work with a brand, to do an
entirely upcycled shoe at scale,
like not just 100 pairs,
like a thousand
or a couple thousand plus pairs
of shoes.